welcome back we are here with the chef
from one of the most coveted hot spots
in New York City like you can't get in
and he actually has multiple of them his
namesake restaurant has been making
headlines for more than a decade I mean
it is the place he is the man and now
he's taking over the world with his
pasta sauce I there's what do you not do
Mario
Carbone I feel very um excited by the
fact that I used to go to teresi Italian
Specialties or specialty at the
beginning before Carbone was even open I
am old school I am OG I go to all your
restaurants how did like the the idea
come of like I I see a a white space in
the marketplace and we're going to go
into this we're going to go into grocery
well I think this is everywhere it's
everywhere yeah it's amazing uh it's
it's taken off and it's kind of crazy
it's it's uh Nationwide but you know we
can only we can only touch so many
people in the restaurants on a night and
we're only in so many cities in the
world so it was an opportunity to kind
of reach a much much broader audience
with our products well it's got your
name on it so you want I have something
with your name on it you
do a little little gift for you a gift
yeah oh
Mario no
no speaking of a
now you're official oh my gosh okay I
just became the coolest person ever all
right well take us through the dish what
are you teaching us to make today I see
Lobster I'm drooling I've tried the
pasta sauce I cooked with it the other
night at home um and I loved it it's got
kick and spice and I like spice so this
one's got a little kick little extra
kick to it this one's a little fancy uh
so we're doing kind of a creamy spicy
Lobster capalini I love a cream I love a
lobster I love a
spicy fancier than it is this is a
pretty quick thing sliced garlic super
thin olive oil these are Italian long
Hots and res red long Hots long Hots you
got some long Hots and red Fresnos sorry
this is the way my brain works Mario I
in my parsley early I like to fry the
parsley in the The Parsley this is a
little bit of green peppercorn and then
we're going to need to get to our
lobster right so we'll let this kind of
sit in a second here that looks so
beautiful so this can be kind of a
dangerous job and I wanted to kind of go
through it really quickly so often you
want to you know you're you think to
kind of try to attack it with your knife
and kind of break through it but the
slippery shell is going to cause a bunch
of accidents so I have a better way you
sort of once you're steamed or boiled
your Lobster you can kind of easily kind
of detach the tail um and then with a
really strong pair of kitchen shears
which everyone should have you can kind
of just snip through snip through where
the little dangly legs are so you can
just kind of pull them meat out of here
mhm without any use of a knife comes out
perfectly you know the claw the easiest
way to go about it is kind of take a bit
of your aggression out here take kitchen
towel these are pretty big claws so
you're going to give it a good
whack
please oh
oh we got it we got it I don't know what
that Lobster did to you but um back to
our sauce so we're going to take our
beautiful I'm just like hanging out with
my hammer please put the hammer down um
we're going to add our Lobster meats or
our
sauce
Knuckles give that a quick little
fry so this is raw Lobster in this
boiling parsley garlicky chili oil how
long lightly steamed lobster right now
it needs a little more cooking minutes a
minute what's when should you pull that
out shrimp and lobster for me I think
can take a little bit more cooking than
people think you by the way I don't like
that translucent cook I think it's nasty
I agree with you thank you I agree with
you I I want I want a little
opacity opacity is the word of the day
bust out all my words we're going to add
little spicy Pock you're going to add a
little Carbone yeah yeah
yeah little bit of cream will act as
kind of obviously the richness but also
a little bit of a cooling agent and it's
going to round this whole thing out well
if you eat something spicy they hand you
milk exactly right um okay we have a
trivia question going into commercial
Sarah is myel right over here okay I
have a trivia question for you and
there's um something you could win if
you get it
right that's exciting okay so according
to the international pasta organization
how many different pasta shapes are
there is it a 200 B 600 C1 ,000 now
don't tell me we're going to go to a
quick commercial break get your noodle
going and we'll be right back to see if
you can win the
prize